salut salut c'est qu'il est minime mais
voici en compagnie de l'équipe
formidable du film bienvenue à marly
gomont julien rambaldi
le réalisateur monsieur marc zinga moi
le rôle de mon papa madame aissam avec
un envol de maman ou alors on est tous
là pour vous parler un peu du du projet
du film on s'est empressé d'accepter la
dernière au projet parce qu on est tombé
sur un scénario qui était super bien
écrit avec une histoire très émouvant ce
très drôle à la fois et est en plus
l'occasion pour moi de rencontrer une
super partenaire qui m'a tirée vers le
haut dans ce film alors tu as découvert
kamini à 10 ans quasiment jour pour jour
c'est un truc de ouf avec le clip
marly-gomont à l'époque le ballon mais
qui était déjà hirsute burgos hugo boss
et reçut merci la partie et il était
donc seul noir au milieu des vaches dans
la campagne française dans un village
donc maintenant tout le monde se
souvient le monde qui est marly-gomont
qui est vachement un moment c'est qu'on
a découvert ce qui amène derrière sera
parodique c'est l'histoire d'une famille
décide de devenir le quitter le congo et
de s'installer dans un village où on ne
les attend pas d'ailleurs on n'a vu
aucun noir avant de se remettre ça c'est
vraiment vraiment les premiers les
premiers jeux
mais les colons du coup quand il en soit
rendez vous en salle on vous attend dans
l'espère que ça vous plaira